in five four three two one
welcome everybody to the genius brain
podcast for those of you who haven't
heard about the genius brain podcast
it's a podcast about anything and
everything we are here just to keep you
company on your commute we talked about
feelings we talked about giggles we
talked about laughs and genius brain
just means that it's just a bunch of
dumb people talking today so yeah you
agree yeah yeah you dumb today we have
my Fiat Mike Allyson my girlfriend
fiance I like girlfriend though I like
boyfriend - I like girlfriend girlfriend
you look good for my girlfriend
mariel song everybody I don't you
introduce it like terrace house right
now I forget they say hey look at you
again you and your terrace
I love terrace house I know you've been
watching the old series now that we're
done with part two of Tokyo I I just
started watching the terrace house a
loja state the Hawaii one and there's
this kid that is the reason why I
started watching the terrace house
Hawaii one is because in the new season
there's just kid named I think his
performer name is Eden Kai but his
Japanese name or his action name is you
see a games a Yusuke is a very
interesting kid number one it's kind of
hard to hate him because he's very sweet
and adorable he has like a he has like a
very untarnished innocence about him so
he's very young at that and that's
serious he's like 18 18 when he comes up
but even for 18 year old he's very
innocent like he has trouble making eye
contact with people when situations
become awkward or people point things
out about him he stares down at the
floor he kind of curls up and balls up
which is a quality in guys specifically
Asian dudes that I see a lot they
[ __ ] him yeah you were I mean I
haven't seen Aloha
I just
like a clip of it today but you were so
emotionally invested in this guy you're
just like if I see him I'll punch him
I'm like reason why I say I'm gonna
punch him is because I love him though
it's not because I know yeah it looked
like you really care about rooting for
him yeah you know I mean because he's
such a good good dude but he has every
like quality that I hate about certain
like Asian guys that I used to grow up
with like they had this thing like I've
talked about this before where I I hate
people who use the excuse that good nice
guys finish last and friendzone mm-hmm
those are the two things I hate the most
that guys use when when really what
happens in these situations specifically
when it comes to people who say got nice
guys finish last mm-hmm you're really
not that you're not a nice guy nice guys
don't have to say that the nice guys
yeah yeah yeah like cuz you told me
about a situation back in the day where
there was a guy who really liked you was
it it was in Taiwan before you left
oh that one okay Oh which one it was the
guy that was in Taiwan and he wrote the
the letter for you oh no that wasn't
college that wasn't college he I guess
they're kind of similar if you think
about it like because uh well he who he
was always in my friends oh well he put
himself in the friend zone like he was
always just a butt buddy and he never
asked me or anything like not that I was
interested in like I thought we were
totally friends and then towards the end
right after right before we graduated he
decided he's like hey you want to go
like just go yeah I don't know where and
I was like oh yeah sure let's have
dinner you know but it was just
one-on-one I was like oh this is weird
and so just like that fish yeah they're
talking they're like oh my gosh he's
he's asking you I'm like I didn't think
like that that we were just friends but
then now that you guys say like that
like how am I supposed to approach this
and so it was like this really fancy
steak house by the way okay like that
good free meal okay I did get a free
meal and you know it dressed up or not
but really awkward honey yeah it was
kind of awkward was because he couldn't
really start a conversation or what was
awkward is because you knew that he kind
of wanted more yeah
well I don't know if it's more but I
knew that it was more than just a friend
thing because he didn't do that to all
the friends it was just me just you and
you know before we left he wrote me a
very nice letter tight of course letters
always work home I'm saying make sure
you write that letter cuz after I left
the town though I was like I'm never
going back up and I mean I he wrote a
letter to you laughter when you left
yeah after we're done the whole [ __ ]
point of that guy I think it was just
like a closure maybe of like how he felt
about me but that said I didn't well I
guess what I'm asking is like when he
wrote you that letter what was he
expecting a response back like hey I'm
not leaving because after I read this
letter I have to stay here for you I'm
coming back for you and then you know
Korean drop music place into Peck when
you're about to leave you turn around
and he grabs your wrist and then the
cliffhanger yeah it's like foggy with
the glitter and zoom no no I just text I
remember like hey thanks for the present
yeah and that's it that's the thing
about that kid you scared to write it's
like he's very innocent and he's like
miss reading into a lot of these
situations like when a girl like for
example he is an amazing musician he
plays a guitar really really well so I
think with with the girl her name is
what what was her name again Lauren
Lauren sign right so Lauren shows
interest and she's excited about his
music and he kind of takes that as oh
like this might be a good segue for me
to ask her out any interest he thinks
exactly any interest which is true like
when you see a girl who's interested in
something that you're doing that's
probably your avenue to really establish
whether you're gonna be friends or you
could show interest problem with him is
he just stood there like a dumbass like
like he just stands there with his with
this with his mouth open just waiting
for something to happen and he's
creating these narratives in his head
you know I mean how do you know so well
cuz when I was younger I was just like
that I knew it but that's what the these
are the qualities that we don't like in
people because we see that in ourselves
right and so you were like yeah play
music and no but that's more like how I
was when I was in high school like 14 15
maybe you know I mean like that age so
it's like I think for him because he
hasn't dated yet that he hasn't
experienced those these feelings right
but it's just like for what for example
he's not a bad-looking guy super
talented right very sweet very nice and
the one missing piece that he's missing
right now which I always talk about is
confidence his shoulders are down he
kinda had his tails beat his tail
between his legs
yeah yeah if he would just stand up
straight yeah talk to her look her in
the eye but instead when he talks to her
he just stares at the floor flips around
and it's not a very attractive
he doesn't have swag if he had deal yo
swag he's get all do the basketball
player of it yeah exactly that
conference relax on my couch give me the
UH exactly so in the new season that guy
has a lot of confidence or even um even
like that goofy confidence that Pepe has
right so pepe if you guys don't know is
this if you watch terrace house you
could tell him really into this [ __ ] is
this Italian immigrant he moved to Japan
to be a manga artist he's also confident
- but he's in the goofy like anyway
right cuz geeks can have confidence -
lolly so Yusuke has none of that [ __ ] if
you had as music confidence maybe
they're just episode that you see where
there's very weird interaction between
Lauren and him or he's trying to ask her
to go to North Shore so cos they're on a
wall so he's trying to ask her to go to
the North Shore with him but then
obviously other people came along too
because he didn't really establish
himself so the reason why I get
irritated about this because this is
really the interaction that you see from
guys that what really happens but the
story that they tell is different not
from Yusuke but other people right so
guys will be like oh man like I'm just
stuck I'm stuck in the friend zone these
nice guys finish last it's like no it's
not that nice guys finish last
the girl was never interested in you in
the first place yeah you know what I'm
saying I
in general our guys like that I don't
think all guys are like that but I'm
talking about a specific type of guy
that's very bitter towards women because
they are inadequate it is not the girls
fault
I don't like it when guys blame girls
for not liking them a girl doesn't have
to [ __ ] like you they do not they do
not owe it to you to give themselves to
you because you're a nice guy you tell
them you tell them I hate that [ __ ]
because number one - it's it's like I'm
not I'm not mister you know what captain
save-a-ho mr. feminists or [ __ ] like
that but I don't like it when people say
that my you owe me your feelings because
I'm a good guy Mike how [ __ ] dare you
just be that's great you're a nice guy
you you're supposed to be a nice guy but
it's up to you to show somebody kind of
what you can offer them in a
relationship sense and on top of that if
you're a nice guy we won't be nice to
you exactly why why would we treat you
like crab when you're a nice so we will
give we will approach you very nicely
and they receive that I was like oh
we're moving on we're getting something
here it's like no is that social
awkwardness where they can't tell what
flirting is is right like because
because if they see them right and they
see that girl with another dude and they
kind of behave different it's like okay
that's attraction yeah I mean like
wouldn't when when you have interacted
with this girl she's very sweet she
smiles she's last she's having a good
time doesn't mean she's attracted to you
right it just means that you're a nice
guy is she's a nice girl and you guys
are having good interactions now if you
wanted to establish yourself and create
that relationship you you can't sit
there twiddling your thumbs expecting
things to happen you're not making a
move you're not asserting yourself
you're not letting that person know that
you want something more in a
relationship and by the time that time
passes like it's probably months maybe
sometimes even years for these guys and
then out of nowhere just like in your
case they go let's go on a date what the
[ __ ] what do you mean let's go on a date
yeah where did this come from how are
you supposed to take it like how did you
receive it I I mean we didn't see each
other after that he he lives on up in
NorCal I live in SoCal and it was such a
I don't want to say it's a coward thing
because I don't know the guy
but it's more like you know what was the
point I think for him is I might have
been a closer friend because he knew
that hey we're not gonna able to see
each other every day like we used to you
know it was kind of like terror sauce
because we had same classes every day so
we was each other every day doing the
same activities and he knew that okay
this is gonna come to an end maybe he
had some feelings for me and he's like I
need to put a closure into this so he
gave me a letter it was what was the
letter wait I'm not reading this
correctly this is not a letter why is it
rhyming yeah something about sunflower
and
for its bitter make you feel sweet or
did you they make you want to throw up
mm neither I was just kind of like
shocked shocked and laughing because it
was just so out of the blue
mm-hmm but I thought it was sweet but at
the same time I knew like or maybe he
already knew that how I felt about him
so I I was like I don't know how to
approach this like how do I responses I
have to say something
so maybe it was card of me I don't know
because I just texted him and said hey
thank you for the gift that's so sweet
of you well I mean what were you
supposed to say do you see right yeah
exactly
that's like I just don't like that I'm
not saying that every person has to
approach a girl the same way right cuz
some guys have a more subtle approach
I'm not a very subtle person mm-hmm you
know like when we interact that was not
subtle at all no you weren't that
friends that friendzone [ __ ] don't exist
to me how I see that I get rejected
right or you accept me either way well
there was no friend no that wasn't even
an option you told me you're like hey
we're not friends because you gave me
the crappiest hug ever I was like that's
a friend hug I keep the Lauren hug yeah
you get the Laurie side hug that's like
no I don't like I don't like that you
know but yeah this podcast is brought to
you by skill share my friends if you
don't know what skill share is I wonder
if you are tackling your new year's goal
to be a better you well guess what let
me tell you a skill sharing a skill
share is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning with
so much to explore real projects to
create and the support of fellow
creative Skillshare empowers you to in
kampala SHhhh
real growth Skillshare is also
incredibly affordable especially when
compared to pricey and Princeton classes
and workshops an annual subscription is
less than ten dollars a month I have
been using Skillshare to sharpen up my
photography and videography skills
because you know I use that on the daily
and I'd like to learn at my own pace so
a lot of traditional learning you don't
have that you have to learn what
somebody tells you to learn they give
you all these tests well some of us like
to learn in our own spare time and when
we have a busy life we want to be able
to pick and choose when we can do it and
Skillshare with their huge database of
knowledge has got your back baby
so Skillshare is a proud sponsor of
genius brain explore your creativity at
Skillshare comm slash brain and get to
three months of premium membership
that's two whole months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes for free
get started and joined today by heading
to Skillshare comm slash brain that
Skillshare comm slash brain I mean but
you know what I I think he just wanted a
closure because we don't we're not
friends anymore
yeah ok it was a good chapter on my life
for me I don't feel like you wanted
closure because you wrote a freaking
poem what do you think I was trying to
emotionally move you with the poem
because if it was closure we were just
been like hey it would have been I think
just a regular letter which already is
weird for an adult to do that depending
on if that was the type of interaction
that you guys already had it was like
something cute that you guys already did
but you guys didn't do you know what I
mean cuz he because he was scared to
talk to you in person he could have just
talked to a person who said hey he what
I mean he is a nice guy yeah I'm pretty
sure he's a really nice dude I may be he
is the stereotype nice guy then yeah I
just yeah it's but I don't know I mean
that like bad news is his name you
scared you scared you scared he maybe he
just didn't have those kind of
opportunities but he's tried he tried in
that shot that's what I appreciate about
in the most yeah is that no matter what
like I said this frustration for me like
I'm super into this too is because like
I'm the older version of him like I like
him a lot you know yeah door looks
really adorable he's actually he's a
cute looking dude yeah yeah I mean it's
just it's literally as posture that
makes them unattractive
like compare him in dukkha who does not
even try like this guy do you skate he
actually talks to people listen and go
all out you know make reservations even
though he ended up meeting him by
himself
dude there's this part in the show where
if they made him look like the biggest
[ __ ] losers I've ever seen in my life
and it made me mad a little bit I'm like
yo don't make my med you stay look like
that man he's my man you ski I love you
don't make you skate look like that you
know they didn't do it once but they did
twice fried catfish alone in the patio
17 different angles to show how alone he
know so sad but you know given I mean
maybe that's why we like him because he
gives all out or he gives everyone yeah
he tries he listens yes though a lot of
people are giving him bad advice yeah
but Luke on the other hand who which is
another guy in the ladies season of
Tara's house he doesn't even try he just
like finds one thing and just goes for
it mmm like he doesn't look for options
he doesn't ask people for advice like he
went on that day to like freakin hour
and a half out in this I don't know next
to the ocean to get sushi and it's like
why do you have to go so far you could
just find something nearby and do more
activities these blue guys the young kid
right he's the young king wants to
become a spider-man okay well Luca is
different on the second season or the
season that we're watching now yeah it's
because if I ever meet this kid like
Luca if I ever meet you most likely I
mean you're not gonna learn how to speak
English even though you're trying cuz
you're good to think he's dumb as rocks
like from what the wit from the show the
way to show portrays him he's so he's
also lovable too though like I actually
like the kid a lot I did at first I
thought he was adorable at first but
later the more we see him
I personally for me at least like I'm
like you are a hopeless child I even
trying you're not even doing it he is
trying though because think about it
though he's trying but I also think if
he's been sheltered so much so and the
number two I think he's just he's not as
sharp as other people are so think about
it like this if he wasn't trying there
was an episode where he said he wants to
learn adults
even though he already is a [ __ ]
adult and remember he made that
disgusting broccoli a Costner the bunch
brats oh this [ __ ] is so [ __ ]
hit this here's the thing there's the
internet if you wanted to learn how to
make a carbonara pasta look up a YouTube
video bro yeah this what this fool does
he takes a boiling pot of water on
season those broccoli in it and that his
pasta in it and then because he wants to
make a carbonara he just cracks eggs
right to water and but this is how
sweetie is - he doesn't want to waste
food so he just eats the whole thing
anyways he's also very innocent he's
very know he's very nice but that's what
saying he's trying he's that's a well
the difference but a trying yeah is that
one talks and listens and does his
research the other one he just doesn't
because he's dumb he's just I don't know
I'm like I see you have potential you
got people around you you could you know
dude he's a cutie he's very pretty
yeah by the way you know everybody has
their pace and I'm not talking about if
they're dumb or not and just just it's
just how much are you willing to try he
is trying though remember he also had a
conversation with one of the other
housemates where he didn't like the way
that he was he was portrayed on terrace
house so he wanted to change himself and
he asked her like hey can you call me
out when I do these things and he tried
like he keeps trying to cook this is so
funny - because everybody has when they
come to this thing called Terrace house
and I haven't given background it's a
reality Japanese reality TV but it's
very natural in the sense that things
aren't there isn't a narrative that's
really forced because you're seeing
something that happens within a single
episode can span from like like a whole
week the whole week or or two weeks and
so they condensed that week or two weeks
or maybe even a month into one episode
and so you're seeing like natural
interaction and they cut and edit it
very well and so that's what terrace
house is a reality TV show that doesn't
have life force drama or anything it's
just these people are put into a house
and you're going to see how they
interact and so and you learn so much
about their culture that it's just so
fascinating and then they have what six
hosts five four five or six make like
comedic commentary hole
yeah so essentially what we're doing
right now yeah but they're so [ __ ]
funny I love them dude and so like you
know going back to this kid Luca Luca or
this guy Luca yeah so him
I see his effort and he's trying a lot
it's just like watching him fail is so
funny because he just he smiled and
laughs about everything he's just
smiling and he's trying he's trying he's
trying and he doesn't even get
frustrated he's just like mmm it's not
working let me try again
let me try again Yusuke is a lot more
mature than him but he kind of just
takes everybody's advice too
straightforward right so they go oh when
you date a girl you should wear a white
shirt or this shirt
he doesn't even question why he goes why
why would I wear a white shirt her or a
burgundy shirt what does that mean right
he just goes oh I heard from an older
person that this is what I should wear
so I'm gonna wear this burgundy shirt
bro what the [ __ ] you sound like a
five-year-old [ __ ] you know it sounds
like he hasn't gone through a tough
times to question those like it's not
even in his mind because he never had to
there was a scene to where they're
asking he's asking this part where well
he's not asking this part doesn't make
any sense basically somebody gave him
the advice then when you go on a date
with the girl in order to establish that
you are attracted to them you should try
to touch them and hold their hand it's
like who the [ __ ] told you that man what
he's a virgin by the way which is cool
but what other virgin gave you the
advice like that you should just come up
and just grab a girl's hand in that has
never ever worked in the history of men
unless that girl was literally attracted
to you yeah you know like it was out
there already
I'm glad the other guy the roommate said
well you gotta try to make sure read the
room because it might seem a little
rapey that's what he said it might come
off as sexual harassment I think you
probably learn from that lesson from
that first very first date like oh I
should ask if there are available for
dinner before making reservation if he
didn't say that part mm-hmm you know
because in the in the awkward situation
is that they know that she's not
attracted to him but they it's not their
business to tell him like don't go out
on this date because it's also a great
life experience for him too it's a good
learning experience to get rejected
dumped yeah totally so I kind of
like the fact that they didn't step in
but they kind of gave him a small assist
in the census don't touch it like that
yeah yeah I gave him a little hint yeah
because if he didn't do that he would
have tried to hold her hand
maybe maybe late I mean the only did was
watch a movie though she didn't give him
a hug either no not at all because she
didn't want to give that message I think
she did you know she could have handled
it better of course because it was kind
of awkward and sad yeah she thought I
just like soaked away and they walked
away from them
but I think she did the best that she
can in a very good for good reason she
did the best that a 18 year old can do
exactly can't forget that there I'm
giving her grace because she's an 18
year old I'm giving him a lot of grace
because he's an 18 or an 18 year old she
does a lot yeah she does do a lot like
she's really talented in stuff does
modeling she does art I don't know if
she goes to school
I only saw that one episode but I think
she's also just from what I observed
from the show she seems like somebody
who prefers a long time because she kind
of mentioned it before but looking at
her interactions with people she does
appreciate her own space her own time
and her own time to think and do things
her way you know and then that's like
you know when you're in a living
situation with a lot of other people I
think that's what stresses are out yeah
is that she's with other people she has
to be considered a very yes so that
makes sense why she was getting stressed
out and crying is because things that
she didn't have to consider she was
trans trying to be a responsible respect
her family of going to that heard
Thanksgiving you know schedule with them
realizing a whole crap I have another
family that I need to think about now
and think about their feelings yeah so
and there's been this part of the
episode what happened was she
essentially what they were asking one of
the room one of the roommates were going
to leave and they didn't want to
outright say it but they were asking her
to make time for this day and it was on
Thanksgiving Day to have like a
roommates Thanksgiving before you go off
and have it with your family it's done
essentially how she responded was very
childish in the sense of like as an
adult if you have prior engagements that
you can go to you can make things work
Yeah right
and so it's like hey if like for example
if I had two Thanksgivings to go to my
parents said that Thanksgiving was
important to us as a family I will tell
them hey I also had this other important
event I will
go to it earlier and I'll make sure that
make it to dinner and we'll have a great
time it's very simple even if they say
no you should address it yeah her excuse
was like would the way she phrased it
was like my parents aren't gonna be
happy about that but I'll deal with it
well if you were gonna deal with it why
did you have to mention that one part
they made the whole conversation salary
yeah and so that's her being an eighteen
year old and not knowing how to handle
an adult situation that's I think that's
yeah that's definitely like kind of a
life experience of because you haven't
thought about oh how you're the person
now you're talking to is gonna feel like
that's not something she realized what
she did that's why the friend was like
then you shouldn't say that because you
have to think about our feelings it's
like because for Lauren she was just
saying like I don't think it cuz in the
scenes she said that I don't think
you're here to listen to understand just
listen to tell me something yeah and
that wasn't the case and so she didn't
realize oh what I just said could affect
people in their emotions too so like now
I have two things to consider she just
did an you know for an eighteen year old
in her life I guess she didn't have that
kind of situations before now she knows
yeah what's the other girl's name again
I don't know I forgot her name
I don't watch long enough to know her
name I uh she's a different the a Avalon
avian avi avi avi yes but but for her um
you could tell that when she was
conversing with her as she's old or two
by the way she's 27 issues and when you
see the interaction between eighteen and
twenty seven-year-old and how they
handle conversations it's different
right so it's not unlike there were
sisters yeah well it sounded like she
was talking to her younger sister
because it's like hey you're not being
honest about what you're saying and
you're saying you just said something
very childish and she wanted to correct
it and so for her she felt like oh
you're not really really trying to
listen to me I said no I I heard what
you said I don't like your approach so
she got frustrated and sorry crying cuz
she knows she's wrong
yeah she'd she know she's wrong you know
because so you know because she called
her out on it yeah and so we and people
know too when you get older your your
your ability to handle [ __ ] is a lot
smaller so once you heard her say like
oh I'll try and ask my parents but you
know they're not gonna like it and be
upset I'll deal with a little bit later
it's just like
she was like well why would you add that
guilt trip part right and she's like
your words aren't really making sense
right now it's like well because she's
like oh I'm just telling you that I made
a mistake yeah and it's like okay that's
fine then don't tell us that your
parents are gonna Americas that's well
how are we gonna feel about that exactly
but like why even throw that in there if
you were gonna still come to the dinner
and make it happen either way like what
was the point of you saying that I think
that seam was like oh that's a very good
like lesson that's a good life lesson
for her it's like you know but you
didn't have to add that like on top of
that thing and what was really
interesting is that I don't know how the
third girl felt I don't know what that
girl name is Naomi Naomi because she's
from Japan that conversation I'm pretty
sure she's like yes Japanese yeah cuz
the hosts were saying like yeah that
situation we wouldn't think about it but
not say out loud so that's like the very
passive-aggressive Japanese culture that
I've said I've seen on the show which is
like oh yeah and then they would talk
about it later talking their back and
then they come back and they talk about
it very generally and they would do that
I mean it's gotten really intense at
certain points to where using what you
see personalities flare up which is you
know the part that makes it very
interesting but it was kind of cool to
see a learning moment for a younger girl
yeah right then I liked it because the
27 year old girl is right you know and
you know for her it was very emotional
because she was being called out on the
spot on top of her dealing with the
stress of moving in the terrace house
and you know she started tearing up a
crime line but you know I like her
though seeing that I'm like cuz
everybody told me I loved Lauren like uh
who's Lauren girl I don't watch it I'm
like oh yeah she is pretty and then like
within a spammer now I'm like I'm
actually a fan of her now
well it's easy to like her because she's
very honest and I think she has no bad
intention oh there's no she has no bad
intention I like I want to say her
name's avian
I'm gonna call her avian but if that's
what it sounds like to me her smile is
Sookie I like her the most on the show
because she's she's very mature I like
her approach to life and also she's very
like Hawaiian so I like it I like
Hawaiian people
well she's not Hawaiian ethnicity
Wiseman you know she's like she has that
Aloha spirit yeah and so when she called
her out on her [ __ ]
I loved it a lot because she did it very
straightforward it was like hey you're
not gonna get a pass on that because
what you said kind of put a damper on
the on the situation and then I kinda
wanted to Naomi because she knew about
the situation and the reason why she
wanted to have Thanksgiving because she
was gonna leave yeah and she didn't
speak up I think yeah if she brought
that up things would have been not as
intense oh she would have understood but
there was a Japanese side at first you
don't want to interrupt yeah it's very
fascinating as American Japanese culture
clashing in there and I love it it's so
fun yeah I mean that I think that's like
the the draw Tara sauce because you get
to see another culture and how they
interact with each other who knew that
was such a interesting thing you they're
so polite cuz cuz we're taught in
reality TV that we only want to see
drama we want to see drunk people we
want to see tits boobs as people [ __ ]
that's what's been sold to us what
reality TV has to be terrace house is
the exact opposite it's it's very
voyeuristic it's it's almost like The
Truman Show you're just watching people
live yeah that's why I like season one
the best because it was it felt the
least forced it was so natural yeah I
think as none of them we didn't know how
it was gonna it was gonna be this
popular so people didn't really have
this motive of like oh coming on to
Terrace house it's gonna change my life
or it's gonna amp up my I don't know you
know my band popularity or whatever so I
think that's why it was just so organic
baby you're so funny so Mariel actually
signed up for terrace house i years ago
i want you i actually want her to sign
up again for the newest season cuz i
want you to be on the show now that we
see oh you don't have to be Japanese to
be in there you don't have to you speak
Japanese so I want you to be on the show
so I can guess beat on it why do you
think you're gonna come on it because
I'm gonna visit you because you're gonna
be on the show and then we're fly to
Japan and I'm surprised you I'm not
saying I can't
like like say that st. okay cuz the
thing is most of the people there are in
their 20s they're very young 20s are in
their teens say 'no who comes on like
every other season she is in her 30s the
oldest one and she only comes out
because she is fun like that girl little
fun to men if you you are not selling
yourself very well i'm actually used
this footage as your audition tape and
i'm so disappointed in you right now you
could make it on the show i need to be
on paris house you're using me so you
could be on her so what are you gonna do
when you're on terror cells you can go
on to look you could know what are you
gonna do i want to know what do you want
to do nothing I'm just gonna talk to you
and I just want to be on there well I'm
not gonna do anything crazy I'm just
gonna you do much like I don't know
bigger stuff what am i when the camera
comes on me I'm gonna start pop like
what do you want to do on terrace house
you want to go on a date no I don't want
it I don't want to be on the show as a
cast member no no I know I'm saying like
what would you be doing like what's your
purpose on terrace that's just adorned
there I don't have a purpose do it I
just want to be on the show that I like
you see I'm saying like I don't want to
be a cast member I'm not saying you
can't cuz you can't speak Japanese only
so you're gonna study exactly I don't
want to be I just want to be on it just
say like hey yo season six you know
episode 17 uh-huh that's me that's me
right there you want me to quit my
career and just go there for hey you
don't know that but that could spark off
a different career for you dude what if
we have a kid by then huh we will not
you are gonna get on the show before you
kid if you don't get on the show we're
not having a kid how about that in your
face right okay I want you to get on the
show so I could just feature on it and
they'll let you I can tell you're using
me why don't you why don't you just
study Japanese and put you on terms you
could you like the bear why not huh why
not I can't be on I can't no you could
do anything David I already know what my
personality said from the first day
everybody's - hey everybody will hate me
the only person that's gonna like me is
that one comedian with the glasses be
exactly who cares I'm just gonna come up
and they're gonna be super
passive-aggressive that glasses guy he's
gonna be so happy you're in there and
he's gonna be like I feel like I'm
seeing myself in there but American I'll
tell you
that guy do you know the only one who's
marry out of everyone I know no weird
yeah but look his personality's funny
funny people always get the ladies dude
I mean yeah - Shay bing bang boom boom
you didn't date anybody until you met me
I'm telling you I mean you know I've
dated people before I met you what
accident I don't know I don't know what
are you a southern belle I've dated
people wait before I met you miss though
I'll tell you somebody funny because
this flower is the will T oh my god I'm
melted like I asked you in a nice iced
tea in a hot summer's day you sound like
you have white lace gloves X and a
Sunday church yeah what's that Rhett I
don't know it comes out here and there I
don't know why comes out no I tell you
this though you fell in love with me
added you know what yeah funny guys are
cool but you mom an Aries so so Aries
don't stuff doesn't make any oh you are
you are gonna believe I don't believe in
horoscopes [ __ ] it's [ __ ] see this
is what I mean strong at it well how
could you Barry how can you believe in
horoscopes tough when you're when you're
Christian I don't like I don't worship
horoscope no it's not worship but it
doesn't make any sense if you're if you
believe in Christianity I don't think
because I think you don't believe it
doesn't mean that you can like you do
for fun also you believe in witchcraft
then you're going to hell yeah are you
gonna do a Ouija board to sinner ha ha
praise the Lord but the thing where they
talk to ghosts the Ouija board be free
no I have no idea where to have I talked
about the cards turrets pirates pirates
goodness girls so funny like she was so
into like Japanese [ __ ] at the time was
a Japanese you she speaks Japanese
but she was like guess where I'm going
with Becky for fun I was like where you
going Joe said meet me say yes to meet
their where's that she goes you know
like the outdoor as a Yosemite
I don't know why yes I know I for the
longest time I thought you
Yosemite was Japanese Japanese Mountain
in the United States no I know it's just
Japanese word I was like oh why do
people like to write this in Japanese
for some reason it doesn't meet they
know it's Yosemite she I have a bunch of
words that she messes up in my eye I in
my iPhone editor what's that orange
flavored jam that you put on toast
orange jam
no what is it what is that what is it
right is that right is that not right
it's not right what is that African
animal that swims in lakes and has a
really big mouth no it's not it's purple
purple and cartoon what is it that's
purple in card - I don't know Donna song
no it's an animal it has like a really
big mouth it swims and swims with
alligators and crocodiles but it's not -
what is it it starts with an H to make
fun of me yes you are it starts with it
is not good for Tara's house it starts
with the H what does it call it's not a
good real fort it starts with the H I
want you to pronounce it oh don't you
know what I'm talking about
without tearing down your face should go
exactly
black eyeliner coming down uh what's the
full word this is what I mean my fiance
is so mean and a hard-headed cuz he
would not let go if I didn't say I
didn't say that he would have gone mad
at me this is what I get for having a
funny man who's also very stubborn you
Ares is it I love it when you
mispronounce words is so funny
so Muriel speaks four languages fluently
and so what I fight and it's not just
her I know I know there's a lot of
people who are poly gods who because
they have to switch in between languages
a lot like the vernacular gets messed up
sometimes in the words get messed up
because I think it's hard to process all
these languages together oh man when I
was in Taiwan mm-hmm I work for the
University for a second the
International Center and no joke I had
to use English Korean Japanese Chinese
all those languages like it's hard
I don't know and like within within even
within like 30 minutes I have to use all
as languages because like the students
would be I don't know coming from
different countries and then when I talk
to the staff they have to be in Chinese
and then sometimes I have to translate
my brain was just like I want point at
one point I was just like ain't you guys
hold on give me a second and I even know
what language I use I was just like dang
he's yeah I need to think about this I
don't know what's going on my brain is
about to explode but it was a lot and
then but I do miss that the fact that I
was able to like just convert you you
said the practice I know I lost my
Chinese I'm so sad my coworker from
Taiwan he came over not too long ago I
think was yesterday he came around I was
like oh what's up and he was like she
knew I was like just like oh that's like
I'm so I'm so um I mean Happy New Year's
I was like oh I'm so like what did I say
I was like hey I'll bet seat like this
I lost my word come down with us though
mmm how do you say that in English
humble mother sir
I don't know how to translate that come
Dongs like
it's like shock but not yeah anyway I'll
just say it Chinese I was like oh she
knew glow oh okay Congo kantola oh let's
go on a gondola gondola it's called a
gondola
it means like a very flyer that you came
around just to say happy new years and
then he was like talking to me in
Chinese and I understood but I was like
I don't know how to say it back and I
got really sad I just had the practice
well your best friend lives right across
the street you could practice anytime at
all she sighs every time I see Chinese
she's like hey if you have to just
practice I know it's like when when I
when I speak if somebody asks me to
speak Korean on the spot it takes me
like an hour to warm up the hardest time
especially when I meet your parents like
when I first see them I can't speak any
Korean because my brain is locking up
and then few words few words then boom
it starts opening up yeah I know where
you're talking about it takes a while
cuz it's because I'm so used to speaking
English and then on top of that I have
to use like tone them my with your
parents cuz I don't talk like that with
my mom and then my means formal yeah
well I have to speak formal Korean to
her parents and because I don't speak
like that to my mom I talk to my mom
like I would talk to my friends in
Korean and I can't talk like that with
her parents so for me it's like like
activating a third language yes you know
what we have to do we just need to fly
to those places travel and just start
using the language if you are on Terrace
house we can make it happen as we saw
maybe they all have terrace houses in
Los Angeles
do you say apply in Korean like apply
for something Taipei I pay I'd never
write type mm-hmm yeah you got it
yeah they say to write a little intro
I'm gonna write my boyfriend who's a
youtuber and he loves that guy whatever
his name is like he really wants me to
apply for Tara's house no you don't say
that you say I am a lost soul and I'm
looking for purpose I wanted to be on
the show two years ago but I thought I
found myself but being in tears house
I think I could find who I really want
to be I miss living in Japan and I want
to find myself by meeting new people you
know I should just write it for me in
English and I'll translate it I'll just
put my name on it
just do what I see what happens if I
don't why if you're very honest you can
get on this show that is not on inside
it is you lost as hell I lost my soul
yes you lost her soul I have a fiance I
lost my soul hey hon son was on that
show and he was married wasn't he
no he has a he had a girlfriend yeah a
girlfriend a few yeah basically they
were too long together for a very long
time yeah right so I'm saying you could
be on it too Ronson though he's an angel
he's an angel he knew everything he had
like came to save that house he said you
could be that person mmm hi it sounds
like 35 I'm like that right 34 30 I
think it was like in his early thirties
yeah that could be you you could be the
wise one you think I would be the wise
one no I don't think so they might have
teach you a couple of things I'm just
gonna be like okay you could be on that
show just do it you know whoever I mean
those for those those of you who don't
watch terrace house he'd be very
confused in this session well we gave a
good enough backstory
just to let you know what the situations
that was going on let's go watch it
just just watch it man like it's funny
because when you see people go through
things that you have gone through it
sparks like this very weird memory you
love that guy I'm talking about it I
could tell that you're imagining about
that boy okay don't say like that what
the hell what's wrong with you I didn't
mean it in a bad way I know but people
don't have contact like I see you just
sitting there just thinking about that
little boy it's like nope nope that's
not what she meant
that little boy ya know it's cuz I'm
rooting for him I'm a fan of his because
I like it when just really good people
you know it's because I think he's a
good person
I'm basing this off watching a show on
one episode and two it's also because I
see him trying and that's the thing that
I don't see a lot of people do and he's
also very honest about his mistakes
right or honest about him about how what
happened at the date so when the date
went bad that didn't go well he was
honest about it
he didn't put up this fluff story about
life he doesn't have that kind of games
yeah exactly but that's what I like
about it what did you think about the
latest season when he asked out I was
very proud of him now that I seen how
much he's grown from the previous
seasons because he was very
straightforward he goes when I come back
I would like to he got that better he
just need to add some swag or confidence
like some kind of yeah I mean he's he's
gotten a lot better but he still
slouches he still looks down his I still
switch at the floor when he's talking to
you yeah yeah yeah you know and he
tosses very soft but I don't know if
it's soft smoking but it's like there's
no emotion - it sounds like a robot yeah
yeah mm-hmm it's like that's not going
to make a girl want to talk to you
that's not gonna make a dude want to
talk to you like you know he's not very
engaging that down the other hand so
cute
yeah Pepe he has like this he's like
goofy yeah you know what's so
interesting the omelet oh no I was gonna
say speaking of bet bet his nickname
that's his nickname right I don't know
what his real name is but that belly
knee or something I don't know when he
said that I read me a might nickname
that my Japanese friend called me when I
was in Japan so my full Japanese name
would be muddy out of it right but they
used to call me Marybeth mauriello yeah
Marriott it was too long so it's muddy
but then I guess like for Mari nickname
they call them muddy pit would have been
crazy if you just lived in Japan I don't
forget for your whole life that would
been crazy like from that point you just
stayed in Japan and you married this
Japanese guy with terrible teeth or it
could have been an American guy who just
knows I'm speaking I mean Japanese it
could be a white guy I can't picture you
with a white dude though you're so
you're so Korean oh I am no yes because
even when people learn your language
they don't there's something about
growing up in the culture that makes
that person different they're still
inherently who they are what they grew
up in so I wouldn't have gotten with the
Korean dude because it would have been
the Korean Korean yeah yeah yeah
what if let's just say this what if I
you flow of it because I went there on a
JK trip right and then I just see you
chillin right right and then you hear
English and you look over and then we
just started having a conversation and
then we just by faith we still end up
together because fate brought us
together that red string of fate Oh what
is that one anime call look at the red
stream I can't remember
silent voice was it Simon boy just
making stuff okay what's that orange jam
called I don't I would have been a toll
different person because I've been in
Japan I'll be like oh I probably have
Japanese accents who knows would you
have stayed in Japan then I wouldn't
have stayed in Japan but then we maybe
we'd have been in long-distance
relationships you starting off that way
and then maybe you would have came back
to the States
so I would have came back but you don't
do long distance in the first year or
two who knows like I said the red string
of fate is different destiny is
different you can't deny you I don't
what if what if that happened and you're
like I don't learn Japanese because this
girl can speak Japanese so well I really
should learn Japanese though I think you
should you understand pretty darn well
which is so weird but I can't speak it
I'm like over Chinese well no you could
speak it it just did you just it just
you just have to rev up I know maybe
that's I should I said to my resolution
your Chinese is like my Korean you just
have to be in it and then it starts to
click again you know Natasha I was poor
cutter under Carter even Kyle okay
Carter even Iran Walker Konya mm-hm
Tony yeah Tony Sarah's already talented
on Daniel
and yeah woody dandy banana coke he
would have a uncle Chaya how he said Oh
ina colletion gonna go do you got
what takaku she put me on hey Mahmoud
and Cruz Otaki hyung go get I'm going to
order - Clank oh she beautiful boutiques
- poor pop Tomoko chirping dog who
opened Oh captain I open the car seat to
see how would I say it isn't hungry hard
ten and read oh she could do bad neither
gee Tony maws a scooter and chinko
thermal energy she wouldn't do so tell
me what's on them they're the mill think
about it oh look a bunch man mm-hmm
Shingo do these all record or what
Hanukkah hmm thereafter then you honey -
honey awesome there Danny hongo venture
that I didn't know anxious then she
young oh she sure needs done up MA
sure dad thought they'd shown each other
says yeah we should do that we should
just like have a full day of just one
language we could but it hurts my head
body up oh yeah that's the whole point
because you're using a different part of
your brain before it gets too rusty and
you can't move it at all it's only gonna
go downhill from here
that's very negative I'm being honest
okay I want to speak Korean right now
for about a minute a minute it's very
hard don't don't I'm in no time okay
we'll try it a little bit okay Oh tuned
in my Road honey
yeah they uh they're cooking game wasn't
you get Kyle you got Gaia was in a guy
cooking game so didn't undo my honey
[ __ ] in their Sunday Meyer I thought
the tail I'm so pale and so shut the
tail but I get whoa
currency right Chico passion on the door
do you know what cooking is cooking you
run into a sale what is here
for a sale well Lyle Malaya cooking neem
cooking me me mmm
sabotage on a customer service customer
mmm ah I wouldn't you guys simmer until
night on a customer service center he's
on I didn't would he go a podcast you
can go home I would Sarah mmm how about
you been there
Mariano well blah Kim Jong Dae any
Monday Kim Jong tokidoki my real mother
sorry so go today pegye and jelly money
she bought her do you know - everything
at are your son doing
Oh Kim Jong well I like that
ah and he couldn't land a he's our buddy
Gandhi got what he got I gotta go hey
come man you silent on super hair G get
you into Revati a body guys someone yeah
Toralei yeah we're up around but yeah
and done not bad that was a minute yeah
but you didn't say much I did say a lot
towards the end how did you feel it's
just there's other things that I want to
say mm-hmm but then I don't know how to
say it that's why you gotta practice
yeah you gotta if I how do you say like
huh what did you want to ask I wanted I
was going to say if I moved to Korea my
Korean would be perfect perfect or good
effect if I said hunger noodle hunger
ooodle hunga hunga gay he's had a caveat
sorry ma'am time done I don't say if I
moved there yeah he's ha Tanya hungry
hmm hangeul gay he's a hyung go get home
chukkamma huncle gays i hunger hadn't
no he's hotter cavion haha yeah you've
had none Hangul what oh he's on me on
Hangul my oh yeah how about it
Tennessee support a poet Idaho says go
out there see like I know all these
words but it doesn't it's not clicking
that I should connect it all together
you know what I mean yeah
I mean it's it's like same thing for me
in Chinese like I know these words like
I didn't I was trying to say stop on the
traffic light yesterday for some reason
I was like how do you say try for lying
in Chinese I'm like I used to use that
all the time because I used to take the
cab I couldn't remember and I was like
wait what's the order is it the now and
are the verb first and it's only because
I didn't practice you know yeah so you
gotta you know your partner is right
here you could totally practice just
like how I could totally practice with
Becky I know I'm giving your own ice to
do it casually I wanted to speak
according to casually talk change over
that cane is more personal personal how
do you say casual tone again mmm pen I
get hung out yeah-yeah guy Hawk one day
Jordan Silverado Nakano how about the
Taj once neat God come also call my dad
so it's basically what I said there's
like I want to speak Korean more
casually by that she was like we'll just
call my dad instead I don't know about
that I can't you're I like talking to
your dad um but you know what the hard
part is about talking to your dad I
don't even talk to my dad because my dad
is very luxury someone we have
conversations when I talk to my father
might my dad's very fun too and you know
the hard part about me talking speaking
to my father is because our relationship
when I was younger was very volatile it
was him telling me what to do how to do
things and then I wasn't smart he used
to call me dumb all the time and because
of that like it kind of ruined our
relationship even into my adulthood now
listen I love my father to death I love
him love him love him but in terms of
speaking to him casually now as friends
there's this awkward air between us
it's not like that with my mom because
my mom beat my ass she told me I was
dumb to when I made stupid mistakes but
she knew how to do balance that out with
love and she also knew when to draw that
line very well my dad didn't know how to
do that when I was younger and I
understand in his case because we were
we were poor we were broke we didn't
have a lot of time I wasn't a great kid
so all he could do was just you stress
the [ __ ] out yeah I mean I get it I get
stressed out you see what happens yeah I
see a glimpse of my father so I
understand so I empathize with them
that's why I love him and I can't fault
him for the stuff that he did you know I
can only hope that I can be better but
it kind of that that stuff has a ripple
effect adhere to your adulthood and now
that I'm trying to speak to him casually
it's very hard unless there's these
moments where we have yeah great
conversation what I mean because because
you have that past history with him my
dad you don't so you could talk to him
yeah and maybe that could help you talk
to your dad yeah I think like one thing
that I really would like to do though is
speak to your dad more casually it's
just I can it's just I can't it takes a
while for me to piece together the words
so it's like I could help I think you
could totally do it if you try yeah I
would appreciate
I could have way more fun speaking to
you I would also appreciate if you would
just call my mom every now and then I
know we just call her I called her up
last month anyway yeah but that was for
New Year's though Happy New Year's or
Christmas it wasn't it wasn't just
casual yeah yeah that's my list because
like my mom I had a conversation with my
mom and you know she said something that
I was like oh I didn't know that she
felt that way she was like yeah she goes
listen she because she was she was
talking about me and my brother and then
you know the Future stuff and she goes
yeah you know I'm really glad that you
met a Korean girl because she speaks
Korean she goes but you know like I've
asked Mariel to have a conversation with
me every every every now and then and
she said that she would but she hasn't
done it so I feel like number one he's
already kind of lied to me which I don't
like but granted he didn't remember at
that time last year before Christmas
before Thanksgiving I was like I feel
really guilty and you're like
and I told you that I want to call your
mom and talk because I feel like we
could have a good conversation but
thinking about that makes me feel guilty
because my mom and I don't do that yeah
I understand that but you didn't
communicate that with her well all you
told her was that that you would so that
stuff that I've you well I just thought
I didn't know I would feel like that
like once it clicked in my head I'd be
like oh I want to call her I was like oh
what is this guilt trip I'm getting
right now to myself because I didn't
understand it for the longest time when
my friend has a similar issue like why
she felt guilty but then it hit me out
of nowhere and I told her I was like I
know where you're talking about and so I
told you about it I was like hey I feel
guilty so I had a lot of hesitation to
call your mom because I do call my mom
but we don't have that kind of
relationship where like sit and talk and
catch up like she doesn't do that it was
pretty funny though dude she I mean yeah
they're both funny they got good sense
of humor they're just kind of extreme
sometimes but we're just all of us were
not a phone person I was on a phone
phone person is that right I used to not
I actually used to hate talking over the
phone because I wouldn't able to see
that person's body language what I used
to do when I was younger is that because
I learned language is very late and like
when I was at when I was a kid so it was
hard for me to understand people by just
listening to their voice so I had to
look at their body language to
understand what they were saying so when
people try to like call like Peggy in
middle school I should be like hey you
know let's talk over the phone I hated
that because I didn't know what she was
saying
what half of the time or maybe I did
know but I was so nervous and
uncomfortable that I couldn't understand
what she was saying really yeah I was
occupied trying to think like what is
she saying what is she saying that I
didn't listen to her this girl it was
like a robot that just never does
suddenly somebody gave her like a human
conscience hi they gave her life because
she liked her best friend Becky by the
way as her best friend she would she
told me that mr. wife yeah her sister
wife which I love by the way too because
she says the same things
that I say to her but for some reason
when she says it it makes sense but when
I say it does it my sister-wife either
way this is what it is noise I will
fight you right now but what she said
was like Becky back in the name when
they first started developing the
friendship she goes we're friends now
we're gonna exchange numbers we're gonna
call each other and she said why why
because we're friends it's what friends
do so I mean cuz prior to that I moved
around a lot right granted I moved
around a lot it didn't really get that
time to build a relationship or
friendship with kids at school because I
Elementary I don't I can't even count or
even remember all my all the schools
that I've been to
but middle school finally stuck around
to one location and Becky came around
and then we exchanged numbers and so I
wasn't used to talking over the phone
like friends calling and stuff that was
just not a thing so when she called me
I'm like why you keep calling me every
day and she's like this is what friends
do I'm like oh what okay I said it's
like I'm learning to be friends it's
it's what friends do people people yeah
I didn't really know how to socialize I
was just in my own world I guess but
that said so I wasn't a phone person and
it wasn't until it wasn't until I came
back from Taiwan and I started commuting
to Culver City to go to fullscreen
because it's such a long commute that I
just didn't know what to do and we
didn't have Spotify back then so I just
called my friends mm-hmm and by then I
was pretty comfortable I guess with
myself and like talking to people and I
guess I don't know somehow like oh
talking on the phone is actually really
fun prior to that I didn't like it
because I like when I was in Japan for
example when I was in other countries
like in Japan I even learning Japanese
like I have to look at their body
language to understand like what they're
saying because it's just their voice
it's hard for me to understand and so it
was until later on like after college
you know when I finally got comfortable
talking over the phone so it's still
fairly new and so my parents don't like
I mean none of us we really talked on
the phone and like
when you a very interesting relationship
with your parents they'll because I come
from a family that's very touchy-feely
yeah I mean which is not normal why
Koreans family I don't know I the the
Korean families that I know growing up
they were like that right but I guess
maybe they're not as typical that I've
seen from other Korean families though
hmm
so when I lived in my small world
whatever set my mom my parents by the
way don't have too many friends like
they they keep their circle really tight
and the circle that's really tight and
they kind of behave like us too
very lovely very friendly all hugs all
kisses like I give I kiss my guy friends
if I wanted to like I'm very okay that
[ __ ] too like I'm I'm I like my friends
what is my friends like I like if you're
in my really tight close circle like
we're family yeah I mean like you see
like a home girls I'll get then kisses
on the cheek I love them like I'll tell
them I love you United mean is because I
I really it's just like that's family to
me we've done that since we were kids
you know I mean something that I saw I
still get my mom kisses you I mean right
so like we grew up like touch is in it's
weird to me when people see touch and
physical touch is only a sexual thing
you know I mean you see I'm saying yeah
it's odd for me cuz you see as a sexual
thing only but it's just cuz like Wicca
still be just as close but don't have to
apply that we just didn't grow up with
it well that's why I'm saying like
because I think that's an awkward thing
for a lot of people I'm not saying
everybody has to be like that I'm just
saying like with my group of friends
that I have had that's just how we fit
that's how we've been you know which I
love I think I'm honestly I envy people
who are very comfortable and natural
with hugging and like showing affection
like saying I love you and stuff cuz so
funny my co-workers they're so good at
it they're so good at it and they're
really all good friends so they say it a
lot they hug a lot and I watch them I'm
like wow this is amazing and I get
really happy for them but I think I give
off the energy I'm like oh I don't do
that because I'm just like nope I don't
initially
my body's just like a stone and so one
time I mean when they if they come and
approach me I will do it like I'm more
than happy to do it I just don't know
how to even grow but is actually
different I will accept it but I can't
it's not a daily thing for me yeah and
so one day I brought it up to one of the
girls and she was like oh yeah I could
tell I can tell I'm like oh yeah because
you stiffen up like a board like why
probably but everybody's different
there's no right or wrong way yeah it's
just envy it though like I wish I mean
our bodies are like obviously it adds
endorphins or something to our body
because we love it and also to sometimes
like I understand on from a woman's
perspective too because I think a lot of
guys like I didn't I didn't really think
about this until it was addressed to me
like I guess this is good this would
come off as offensive to a guy if they
heard it or not right but like you know
a couple of home girls were like because
I they would see that I would hug these
girls right I give them a kiss on cheek
and say goodbye anyway not a gay dude
straight dude you know and then we kind
of have like a very fun like flirtatious
friendship or whatever whatnot but this
literally don't find him attractive at
all right and kind of and one of the
girls were talking about in passing she
was just like she was I like the way
that you interact with me I think what
do you mean she goes like I could tell
that when you hug me
or like if you gave me like a kiss on
the cheek goodbye like it's just because
you love me as a friend there's no like
other meaning it's very comfortable I
don't feel like you're you stare at me I
don't feel like any of that [ __ ] like
I'm not like I don't see you that way at
all you know she go but she goes she you
guys I even feel like sometimes with my
guy friends we're casual friends and
stuff and we're good I feel like if they
tried to give me a hug the way you gave
me a hug I would feel like they're
trying something different she does but
when you hug me you embrace me but it
feels like it feels warm and it feels
very inviting you know it's like which
is true like I don't have an ulterior
motive I'm holding you because I care
about me right all right I've had those
hugs before where a was just not just
like well this feels weird
yeah I was like me me like kind of catch
myself really I I should say foot step
away because I also hug girls to see my
hug dudes too so it's like like you know
when I give big hugs to a girl
the guys get the same huh it's not a
different hug than a guy gets or girl
goods see it's it's a how do I say
you're so natural with it that it's
comfortable
yeah even like the person who you give
hook no understands that yeah you
totally receive that and so I don't I I
don't know if I do
I I can't do that and I envy that a lot
we check ahead no but I do because I
want to but it just doesn't I'm I'm used
to doing something else that it's hard
to get rid of that habit mhm and I feel
like it's getting even harder cuz it's
it's funny because here I don't they see
me as like the girl who doesn't hook
right who's not very like touchy when I
was in Asia it was a whole different
story
because I'd be like I've tried a hug and
they'd be like uh they were the ones
that are like oh yeah so I'm like oh I
should not do this and I get so used to
that that because it's a different
meaning over there when you hug someone
well that's why I was on Terrace house
I'm saying like people would hate me
because I'm so unhappy knees right cuz
if I like somebody I want to hug them
even in the own this the only show that
I've seen on Terrace house the Aloha
State because it's in you know a
whatever territory of the United States
where it's more American where they hug
they actually how do me hug me
like they actually hug in this one right
because I think it's in America yeah but
in Japan
none of them hugged yeah they didn't
unless it was like a log like they're
leaving forever they have each other but
even though that hug is like a little
pat yeah like when I see Bart I get my
hug yeah I get Bart a huge hug I wonder
what it been like to live in one place I
kind of like that you got to grow up and
live in other places like you really
lived a life that I wish that I was
brave enough to live when I was younger
but I wasn't like number one I get going
outside of Sacramento mm-hmm made me
anxious like I would like you'll freak
out but that's because that's your real
home that's where your real friends are
your close friends your family your
history your memories everything's there
so it makes you anxious I didn't have a
place like I could I'm so dee dee
attached to all the places that I lived
yeah even
even I don't know yeah cuz I lived only
for a year or so and then I hop on to
another one
so I don't I have no baggage and those
kind of stuff like I could just hop
around it's almost like as if I have to
hop around to survive yeah cuz if I stay
in one place for a long time I get
anxious that's so I just you know when
we were first going out to she was very
much like that and hurt my comfort zone
is staying in one place in developing
really strong long-lasting friendships
with just a few people her thing was she
she got she felt incomplete if she
wasn't traveling somewhere and trying
these new experiences so when we first
went out and when I told her the
beginning was learning when I was like
hey I don't like long distance
relationships I've done long distance
relationships before and it doesn't work
out for me and so it wasn't even a year
and she was like hey what do you feel
about me moving somewhere else than
working I was like listen I don't I told
you I don't like long-distance
relationships like I like you but if you
move I sacrificed my my lifestyle free
but I had to tell you because I was
honest with you upfront and I was honest
with you at the end and the reason why I
wasn't comfortable with the
long-distance relationship because we
weren't stable I don't I don't know you
like that yet yeah I wasn't comfortable
enough I didn't know you enough and it
to be honest with you I didn't trust you
enough at that point and I didn't trust
myself enough to be away from you right
now if you said remember I told you like
hey if I had a job offer somewhere in
you know Asia for a contract for six
months would you care I was like yeah I
would care but go ahead
like I'm stable with you that's what
you're pushing me to go to Tara's house
you're like you could go there for the
hell away from me already dude go out
there six months let me be butt naked in
the house dude just a half of the rent
and go let me put towels in the sink let
me cut my fingernails at the tables oh
my gosh it'll be a mess no I'd just be a
normal place it's just so funny no yeah
well that was an hour in very fast
podcast now it's fine it's gonna be
confusing for a lot of people feel like
what the hell are they talking about but
I hope you guy got you guys on the
terrace house and I'm actually just
using this as promo to get her on the
show so you could find her
Mariel song at her Instagram two of them
actually right
Mariel underscore
underscore song and then my harmony
story my underscore harmony underscore
story
so my harmony story so you explained it
so my harmony story harmony is actually
in Korean if you say if you want to say
harmony and Koreans hide money which
means grandma and I have a very strong
relationship with my grandma and after
she passed away I have dedicated an
Instagram of drawing her because it's
something that I like to do for fun and
I realized I have a lot of footage and
photos of her and I think it's just fun
to kind of represent how she looks like
under through my eyes with my style and
my future goal for that Instagram is
that I could make a children's book out
of her character and the culture that
she taught me very very cool well you
could see her on that and then remember
genius brain podcast everybody every
Thursday and Sundays you will see it
upload I love you very much
kiss me in the face you can see us on
iTunes Spotify stitcher and those are
the only ones I remember but they're on
every audio platform out there give us a
download give us a listen to and share
it please and I'll see you all next time
you cute booty to tease say the orange
jam